[Musique]
ça a été la plus grande joie de pouvoir
refaire ça juste d'être accueilli dans
ce groupe et ils sont comme hé venez
jouer avec nous allons à travers le monde
et rencontrons tous ces gens et faisons
ce spectacle incroyable c'est génial c'est  ce n'est pas un
concept pour moi ce n'est pas une idée que je peux
pénétrer dans votre expérience et
comprendre qui vous êtes et c'est comme
l'expression ultime de ce qu'être un
sensei est tout amoureux de ces gens,
le spectacle dit que bien que le spectacle
touche les gens fortement  cette émission
a en fait profondément changé les lois
des gens au cours des trois dernières années de travail
depuis qu'elles ont totalement changé tout mon
cerveau c'est tellement plus gros que ce que
nous mangeons même c'est juste tout cet éclair
de souvenirs de différentes villes et
différents pays et différents
continents c'est comme ça  lien tacite
que vous avez avec les gens et vous vous sentez
comme faisant partie de nous ce groupe qui diffuse
un message dans le monde entier qui est tellement
plus grand que tout ce qu'il
y a d'autre  à la télévision en ce moment tant que nous nous
accrochons à l'idée qu'il y a de l'amour, nous
pouvons être incroyablement connectés, le mesurer
par l'impact que cela a sur la vie des êtres humains
et leur cœur, petits et grands
actes d'amour et d'attention et de prendre
soin les uns des autres
ce sera une véritable révolution Je me sens
très très chanceux d'avoir fait partie de
ce voyage cela m'a aidé à grandir et à
grandir en tant que personne en tant qu'artiste c'est bien
que nous soyons tous ici ensemble et que nous puissions le
voir ensemble c'est un
moment spécial et une nuit dont je me souviendrai pour
le reste de ma vie
été des
costumes battant un indice d'octane incroyablement élevé
s'il devait aller aller aller
[Musique]
plus drôle la saison dernière,
notre émission construit des ponts et alimente les
gens que nous saignons tous au réveil, nous avons tous
les mêmes pensées, nous ressentons tous du chagrin
et de l'amour, cela a toujours été à propos de cela
commun  l'humanité c'est  c'est un spectacle qui
dure pour toujours, nous sommes entourés de la meilleure
qualité d'êtres humains que nous puissions
avoir c'était magnifique à chaque fois c'est un
vrai joint chaque lieu de tournage qu'ils portent
cinq douzaines c'était fou
je n'ai jamais rien vu de tel c'est à
cause du spectacle  d'un Brésilien
comme vraiment fou mais vraiment
professionnel, nous pouvons également faire
partie de cela, les voir et écouter
ces histoires et éventuellement utiliser cette
énergie tout en filmant tous ces gens dans
chaque pays, ils sont notre
groupe étendu, cela ressemble juste à un  grande
salle de bal mon Dieu quel voyage
maintenant je suis fier de faire partie de cet heureux
que nous pouvons leur donner une fin qui a été
satisfaite
vous